ladies and
gentlemen my name is Willie woner willly
won is a sort of fixture of culture it
was a dream project from the GetGo I'm
something of a magician prepared to be
amazed this is Willie before the
Chocolate Factory Timothy has the most
extraordinary quality he captures the
essence of Wonka back when he was young
and wide-eyed and full of Hope and
optimism truth is I'm a chocolate
maker he became a real partner in the
movie he would come and he would watch
the takes and we talk about them and
talk about how it can work and he's so
controlled that he can give you every
option and every variation you could
ever want every good thing in this world
started with a dream so you hold on to
yours I'm really grateful to they get to
be playing this role and they get to be
part of this
story this is going to be the best
chocolate shop the world has ever seen
this is a joyous movie this is about
bringing a light into a world that is in
desperate need of it that is to
encourage dreaming and to me that's
hugely inspiring I'm not going to let
you out of my sight really
[Music]
Wonka Here We Go
Mama